Episode 39: Consensus and Protest: Civil Rights
LOCKED
Hi, I’m John Green, this is Crash Course
U.S. history and today we’re going to look
at one of the most important periods of American
social history, the 1950s.
Why is it so important?
Well, first because it saw the advent of the
greatest invention in human history: Television.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green!
I like TV!
By the way, you’re from the future.
How does the X-Files end?
Are there aliens or no aliens?
No spoilers, Me From The Past, you’re going
to have to go to college and watch the X-Files
get terrible just like I did.
No it’s mostly important because of the
Civil Rights Movement We’re going to talk
about some of the heroic figures like Martin
Luther King and Rosa Parks, but much of the
real story is about the thousands of people
you’ve never heard of who fought to make
America more inclusive.
But before we look at the various changes
that the Civil Rights Movement was pushing
for, we should spend a little time looking
at the society that they were trying to change.
The 1950s has been called a period of consensus,
and I suppose it was, at least for the white
males who wrote about it and who all agreed
that the 1950s were fantastic for white males.
Consensus culture was caused first, by the
Cold War – people were hesitant to criticize
the United States for fear of being branded
a communist, and, second, by affluence – increasing
prosperity meant that more people didn’t
have as much to be critical of.
And this widespread affluence was something
new in the United States.
Between 1946 and 1960 Americans experienced
a period of economic expansion that saw standards
of living rise and gross national product
more than double.
And unlike many previous American economic
expansions, much of the growing prosperity
in the fifties was shared by ordinary working
people who saw their wages rise.
To quote our old friend Eric Foner, “By
1960, an estimated 60 percent of Americans
enjoyed what the government defined as a middle-class
standard of living.”[1]
And this meant that increasing numbers of
Americans had access things like television,
and air conditioning, and dishwashers and
air travel.
That doesn’t really seem like a bonus.
Anyway, despite the fact that they were being
stuffed into tiny metal cylinders and hurdled
through the air, most Americans were happy
because they had, like, indoor plumbing and
electricity.
intro
The 1950s was the era of suburbanization.
The number of homes in the United States doubled
during the decade, which had the pleasant
side effect of creating lots of construction
jobs.
The classic example of suburbanization was
Levittown in New York, where 10,000 almost
identical homes were built and became home
to 40,000 people almost overnight.
And living further from the city meant that
more Americans needed cars, which was good
news for Detroit where cars were being churned
out with the expectation that Americans would
replace them every two years.
By 1960, 80% of Americans owned at least one
car and 14% had two or more.
And car culture changed the way that Americans
lived and shopped.
I mean it gave us shopping malls, and drive
thru restaurants, and the backseat makeout
session.
I mean, high school me didn’t get the backseat
makeout session.
But, other people did!
I did get the Burger King drive thru though.
And lots of it.
Our whole picture of the American standard
of living, with its abundance of consumer
goods and plentiful services was established
in the 1950s.
And so, for so for many people this era was
something of a “golden age” especially
when we look back on it today with nostalgia.
But there were critics, even at the time.
So when we say the 1950s were an era of consensus,
one of the things we’re saying is there
wasn’t much room for debate about what it
meant to be an American.
Most people agreed on the American values:
individualism, respect for private property,
and belief in equal opportunity.
The key problem was that we believed in equal
opportunity, but didn’t actually provide
it.
But some people were concerned that the cookie
cutter vision of the good life and the celebration
of the middle class lifestyle was displacing
other conceptions of citizenship.
Like the sociologist C. Wright Mills described
a combination of military, corporate, and
political leaders as a power elite whose control
over government and the economy was such as
to make democracy an afterthought.
In The Lonely Crowd sociologist David Riesman
criticized Americans for being conformist
and lacking the rich inner life necessary
to be truly independent.
And John Kenneth Galbraith questioned an Affluent
Society that would pay for new cars and new
missiles but not for new schools.
And we can’t mention the 1950s without discussing
teenagers since this was the decade that gave
us Rock and Roll, and rock stars like Bill
Haley and the Comets, Buddy Holly and the
Crickets, and Elvis Presley and his hips.
Another gift of the 1950s was literature,
much of which appeals especially to teenagers.
Like, the Beats presented a rather drug-fueled
and not always coherent criticism of the bourgeois
1950’s morals.
They rejected materialism, and suburban ennui
and things like regular jobs while celebrating
impulsivity, and recklessness, experimentation
and freedom.
And also heroin.
So you might have noticed something about
all those critics of the 1950s that I just
mentioned: they were all white dudes.
Now, we’re gonna be talking about women
in the 1950s and 1960s next week because their
liberation movement began a bit later, but
what most people call the Civil Rights Movement
really did begin in the 1950s.
While the 1950s were something of a golden
age for many blue and white collar workers,
it was hardly a period of expanding opportunities
for African Americans.
Rigid segregation was the rule throughout
the country, especially in housing, but also
in jobs and in employment.
In the South, public accommodations were segregated
by law, while in the north it was usually
happening by custom or de facto segregation.
To give just one example, the new suburban
neighborhoods that sprang up in the 1950s
were almost completely white and this remained
true for decades.
According Eric Foner, “As late as the 1990s,
nearly 90 percent of suburban whites lived
in communities with non-white populations
less than 1 percent.”
And it wasn’t just housing.
In the 1950s half of black families lived
in poverty.
When they were able to get union jobs, black
workers had less seniority than their white
counterparts so their employment was less
stable.
And their educational opportunities were severely
limited by sub-standard segregated schools.
Now you might think the Civil Rights Movement
began with Rosa Parks and the Montgomery Bus
Boycott or else Brown v. Board of Education,
but it really started during WW2 with efforts
like those of A. Philip Randolph and the soldiers
taking part in the Double-V crusade.
But even before that, black Americans had
been fighting for civil rights.
It’s just that in the 1950s, they started
to win.
So, desegregating schools was a key goal of
the Civil Rights movement.
And it started in California in 1946.
In the case of Mendez v. Westminster the California
Supreme Court ruled that Orange County, of
all places, had to desegregate their schools.
They’d been discriminating against Latinos.
And then, California’s governor, Earl Warren,
signed an order that repealed all school segregation
in the state.
That same Earl Warren, by the way, was Chief
Justice when the landmark case Brown v. Board
of Education came before the Supreme Court
in 1954.
The NAACP Legal Defense Fund under the leadership
of Thurgood Marshall had been pursuing a legal
strategy of trying to make states live up
to the ruling in Plessy v. Ferguson that required
all public facilities to be separate but equal.
They started by bringing lawsuits against
professional schools like law schools, because
it was really obvious that the three classrooms
and no library that Texas set up for its African
American law students were not equal to the
actual University of Texas’s law school.
But the Brown case was about public schools
for children.
It was actually a combination of 5 cases from
4 states, of which Brown happened to be alphabetically
the first.
The Board of Education in question incidentally
was in Topeka Kansas, not one of the states
of the old Confederacy, but nonetheless a
city that did restricted schooling by race.
Oh, it’s time for the Mystery Document?
The rules here are simple.
I read the Mystery Document.
If I’m wrong, I get shocked.
"Segregation of white and colored children
in public schools has a detrimental effect
upon the colored children.
The impact is greater when it has the sanction
of the law, for the policy of separating the
races is usually interpreted as denoting the
inferiority of the negro group.
A sense of inferiority affects the motivation
of a child to learn.
Segregation with the sanction of law, therefore,
has a tendency to [retard] the educational
and mental development of negro children and
to deprive them of some of the benefits they
would receive in a racial[ly] integrated school
system.
[Footnote 10]"[2]
Stan, the last two weeks you have given me
two extraordinary gifts and I am thankful.
It is Earl Warren from Brown v. Board of Education.
Huzzah!
Justice Warren is actually quoting from sociological
research there that shows that segregation
itself is psychologically damaging to black
children because they recognize that being
separated out is a badge of inferiority.
Alright, let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
The Brown decision was a watershed but it
didn’t lead to massive immediate desegregation
of the nation’s public schools.
In fact, it spawned what came to be known
as “Massive Resistance” in the South.
The resistance got so massive, in fact, that
a number of counties, rather than integrate
their schools, closed them.
Prince Edward County in Virginia, for instance,
closed its schools in 1959 and didn’t re-open
them again until 1964.
Except they didn’t really close them because
many states appropriated funds to pay for
white students to attend “private” academies.
Some states got so into the resistance that
they began to fly the Confederate Battle flag
over their state capitol buildings.
Yes, I’m looking at you Alabama and South
Carolina.
On December 1, 1955, Rosa Parks refused to
move to the back of a bus in Montgomery, Alabama
and got arrested, kicking off the Montgomery
Bus Boycott that lasted almost a year.
A lot of people think that Parks was simply
an average African American working woman
who was tired and fed up with segregation,
but the truth is more complicated.
Parks had been active in politics since the
1930s and had protested the notorious Scottsboro
Boys case.
She had served as secretary for the NAACP
and she had begun her quest to register to
vote in Alabama in 1943.
She failed a literacy test three times before
becoming one of the very few black people
registered to vote in the state.
And in 1954 she attended a training session
for political activists and met other civil
rights radicals.
So Rosa Parks was an active participant in
the fight for black civil rights long before
she sat on that bus.
The Bus Boycott also thrust into prominence
a young pastor from Atlanta, the 26 year old
Martin Luther King Jr.
He helped to organize the boycott from his
Baptist church, which reminds us that black
churches played a pivotal role in the Civil
Rights Movement.
That boycott would go on to last for 381 days
and in the end, the city of Montgomery relented.
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
So that was, of course, only the beginning
for Martin Luther King, who achieved his greatest
triumphs in the 1960s.
After Montgomery, he was instrumental in forming
the Southern Christian Leadership Conference,
a coalition of black civil rights and church
leaders who pushed for integration.
And they needed to fight hard, especially
in the face of Massive Resistance and an Eisenhower
administration that was lukewarm at best about
civil rights.
But I suppose Eisenhower did stick up for
civil rights when forced to, as when Arkansas
Governor Orval Faubus used the National Guard
to prevent the integration of Little Rock’s
Central High School by 9 black students in
1957.
Eisenhower was like, “You know, as the guy
who invaded Normandy, I don’t think that’s
the best use for the National Guard.”
So, Eisenhower sent the 101st Airborne Division
(not the entirety of it, but some of it) to
Little Rock, Arkansas, to walk kids to school.
Which they did for a year.
After that, Faubus closed the schools, but
at least the federal government showed that
it wouldn’t allow states to ignore court
orders about the Constitution.
In your face, John C. Calhoun.
Despite the court decision and the dispatching
of Federal troops, by the end of the 1950s
fewer than two percent of black students attended
integrated schools in the South.
So, the modern movement for Civil Rights had
begun, but it was clear that there was still
a lot of work to do.
But the emergence of the Civil Rights Movement
shows us that the picture of consensus in
the 1950s is not quite as clear-cut as its
proponents would have us believe.
Yes, there was widespread affluence, particularly
among white people, and criticism of the government
and America generally was stifled by the fear
of appearing to sympathize with Communism.
But there was also widespread systemic inequality
and poverty in the decade that shows just
how far away we were from living the ideal
of equal opportunity.
That we have made real progress, and we have,
is a credit to the voices of protest.
Next week we’ll see how women, Latinos,
and gay people added their voices to the protests
and look at what they were and were not able
to change in the 1960s.
Thanks for watching.
I’ll see you then.
Crash Course is made with the help of all
of these nice people and it’s possible because
of your support through Subbable.com.
Subbable is a voluntary subscription service
that allows you to subscribe to Crash Course
at the price of your choosing, including zero
dollars a month.
But hopefully more than that.
There are also great perks you can get, like
signed posters.
So if you like and value Crash Course, help
us keep it free for everyone for ever by subscribing
now at Subbable.
You can click on my face.
Now, my face moved, but you can still click
on it.
Thanks again for watching Crash Course and
as we say in my hometown, don’t forget to
be awesome.
________________
[1] Foner Give me Liberty ebook version p.
[2] http://supreme.justia.com/cases/federal/us/347/483/case.html